si j'assume et
sans ce que je veux
pour répondre à cette
un petit exercice
côté au milieu d'un massif montagneux en
plein coeur de la nature
d'abord je dirais pour moi il ya deux
visions de vie radicalement différente à
gauche en chemin une carrière bien tracé
bien rectilignes bon un paysage
relativement monotone il peut pas
arriver grand chose il ya peut-être
quelques petits nuages à droite et à
gauche mais bon rien de bien menaçant à
droite par contre en voit un
environnement avec beaucoup plus de
relief une multitude de montagne c'est
chacune une aventure de vie c'est aussi
différents paysages qui évoluent au gré
des saisons
il ya des forêts il ya des lacs
potentiellement des barrières
infranchissables qui vont nous obliger à
revenir en arrière
il ya aussi plein d'endroits où on peut
se perdre donc résultat des courses peut
être passer un petit peu en mode survie
s'adapter faire preuve de flexibilité
c'est aussi une attitude de chemin on
peut carrément se planter et faire des
erreurs et franchement heureusement
sinon prendre un risque énorme dans la
vie celui de jamais se tromper c'est
aussi une autre possibilité c'est de
faire des rencontres incroyables et dans
ce genre d'univers aussi divers que
variés
on peut aussi s'intéresser à une
multitude de choses en gros se coucher
moins compte tous les soirs ça c'est
quand même important
par contre j'avoue un truc c'est qu'on
peut aussi facilement se perdre
complètement est il important dans ce
type de chemin de vie à choix multiples
de toujours avoir un objectif en ligne
de mire avoir une stratégie et si vous
le voulez bien cet objectif
je vais l'appeler mont everest on arrive
en haut d'une première aventure en haut
de son premier sommet et là on peut
prendre le temps de respirer de prendre
de la hauteur
un peu de meta vision d'avoir 360° de
perspectives et de se dire ok j'ai
toujours mon everest en ligne de mire je
vois je vois où je veux aller maintenant
quelles nouvelles aventures quelles
nouvelles montagnes je vais grandir et
par où je vais aller
eh ben ça c'est un petit peu le un petit
peu le chemin de ma vie un petit peu mon
histoire
d'abord évidemment ça a commencé à
l'enfant sent comme comme à peu près
tout le monde
et déjà tout petit j'avais à peine sept
ans alors j'avais énormément de
difficultés à me plie aux règles en bon
encore aujourd'hui surtout quand elle
les avait pas de sens pour moi et
j'avoue que cette quête de sens du haut
de mes 6 7 ans était déjà profondément
ancrée en moi et puis mon père a une
bonne idée mais assise sur ses genoux et
m'a fait écouter une musique une chanson
de bernard lavilliers qui reprenait un
texte d'un poème de rudyard kipling que
vraiment je vous invite à lire et qui
s'appelle ici est en fait ce poème
commence comme ça si tu peux voir
détruit l ouvrage de ta vie et sans dire
un seul mot te mettre à rebâtir perdre
d'un seul coup le gain de 100 partis
sans un geste et sans un soupir et donc
ce poème continue met en avant une
multitude de valeur et il se conclut de
cette manière si tu es comme ça si tu
respectes ceci alors les rois les dieux
la chance et la victoire seront à tout
jamais des esclaves sous
et ce qui vaut bien bien mieux que les
rois et la gloire
tu seras un homme mon fils et l'a du
haut de mes sept ans j'ai dit mais c'est
ça c'est ça ça me parle c'est ça que je
veux être c'est ça mon everest essayer
de devenir ce type de personne après
j'essaie de me construire avec mes
valeurs et est arrivé l'adolescence ou
là par contre j'ai été confronté
vraiment aimé antivaleurs et autant dire
qu'à cette époque j'ai à peu près fait
toutes les conneries possibles et
inimaginables
par contre toujours en respectant une de
mes valeurs premières jamais faire de
mal aux autres ou du moins de manière
intentionnelle
par contre j'avoue que j'aurais que le
monde partait en cacahuète et que ça
générait énormément de colère en moi
du coup cette phase d'auto destruction
je me suis quand même pas mal perdu
et qu'est ce qui m'a sauvé c'est ma soif
d'apprendre de m'intéresser à tous mais
à n'importe quoi et surtout le sport est
à cette époque je suis vraiment devenu
un toxico de l'adrénaline les sports
extrêmes était vraiment mon univers et
j'ai appris des fois mes dépens ça on
peut dire que ça fait mal à maîtriser la
peur a aimé avoir peur à dépasser cette
sensation parce que quand on dépassait
peur là j'avoue qu'aujourd'hui je fais
pas le malin quoi mais après la
sensation corps sans franchement c'est
jubilatoire
j'ai aussi appris à prendre un maximum
de risques des fois ça a failli me
coûter très cher et que du coup dans la
vie il important de prendre un maximum
de risques mais en maximisant les
précautions j'ai continué à évoluer dans
ma vie je me suis dit j'habitais dans le
sud de la france la montagne pour moi
représente un espace de jeu infini
incroyable surtout pour pratiquer tous
les sports un peu bizarre donc à nouveau
la partie du sud je déménage et je monte
pour finir mes études à l'iut d'annecy
lieu et avec ce désir voilà de vivre
mais passion à fond je gravis mon
premier saut mais je filme et études et
là je me retrouve avec ses 360 degrés de
perspectives et puis en l'occurrence ben
qu'est ce que je vais faire ma vie
maintenant quel sens je vais vouloir
donner à ma vie alors j'avoue qu'on part
du principe je pars du principe que dans
la vie quoi qu'il se passe on conservera
toujours son libre arbitre
le choix de faire au pas faire de se
battre baisser les bras d'assumer le
sens qu'on veut donner à sa vie ou pas
et donc là bas j'avais envie d'assumer
le sens que je voulais donner à ma vie
en l'occurrence deux vivent ma passion
de sportifs et de devenir professionnel
là dedans je fais une petite parenthèse
la petite minute conseil je vais essayer
pas être trop chiant mais je pars d'un
principe aussi c'est que quand on
souhaite prendre des décisions
drastiques dans la vie quand on souhaite
se mettre en situation de risque il est
quand même important de partir tête
baissée plein pot parce que sans
réflexion aucune
ça peut être limite suicidaire il est
aussi important de peser les pour et les
contre de se poser les bonnes questions
parce que quand il va falloir assumer
ses choix et croyez-moi quand on fait
des choix un petit peu fort
ça peut être compliqué à certains
moments choisis la difficulté quand même
il est vraiment important d'avoir une
corde à laquelle se raccrocher des fois
c'est un petit peu notre salut de se
dire attends là au jour d'aujourd'hui
c'est compliqué par contre si j'ai pris
cette décision j'ai bien peser les pour
et les contre et à l'époque c'est ce qui
était le meilleur pour moi donc c'est
vraiment quelque chose d'important
a contrario si on commence à être trop
dans la réflexion et ben moment fait
rien trop de réflexions tu l'action donc
il est important de trouver un bon juste
milieu mais là j'étais décidée j'étais
parti je déménage d'annecy direction des
stations du grand massif pour réaliser
mon rêve devenir snowboarder
professionnels un bon ben ça va pas
aussi bien marché que ça j'ai été pas
suffisamment bon pour en vivre
par contre j'ai été un des meilleurs
mondiaux pour m'exploser me faire très
mal
donc eh bien j'ai appris à vivre sans
argent je n'avais pas pas suffisamment
niveau vraiment pour en vivre
et heureusement qu'il y avait les
poubelles de mcdo et une note de mes
passions la pêche alors du poisson j'en
ai bouffé tous les jours j'ai un moment
je me pose même la question est-ce que
je vais pas avoir des écailles qui vont
sortir à la place des poils parce que à
force de manger du poisson mais mais
j'étais heureux je vivais mon rêve j'ai
assumé à fond sauf qu'à un moment elle a
bien fallu se rendre à l'évidence
si je continue comme ça ça va mal finir
donc j'ai fait quelque chose que je ne
referai plus en l'occurrence de réagir
dans l'urgence de réagir dans la panique
et j'ai sauté sur le premier job venu en
l'occurrence d'être commercial pour de
la pub dans une boîte de sport alors je
faisais tout ce qui me plaisait pas du
télémarketing
je vendais un produit qui avait aucun
sens pour moi en plus en quelle je
croyais pas malgré tout c'est super
important
c'est bien dans la vie de savoir ce
qu'on veut faire c'est aussi vachement
cool de savoir ce qu'on veut pas faire
ça ça nous aide à progresser au delà de
ça j'étais à annecy j'ai fait une super
rencontre j'ai rencontré mon épouse qui
annécienne et qui a eu la bonne idée de
vouloir finir ses études dans le sud
là j'avais vraiment prévu de pailhères
tournée du tout moi j'étais bien dans
les yachts j'étais bien dans mes
montagnes
sauf qu'il a fallu faire un choix est-ce
que je reste seule et sans
zèle dans mes montagnes où est ce que je
décide de la suivre et de redescendre
dans le sud avec elle et son je voulais
donner à ma vie vivent dans l'amour à
ses côtés donc déménagement de haute
savoie et on arrive dans les alpes
maritimes
je vous en parlais la pêche sportive
c'était vraiment quelque chose qui me
passionnait et j'ai trouvé dans la
magazine de pêche une annonce qui
proposait un poste de directeur de
magasin pour un magasin de pêche
spécialisé là bas donc ébats soyons fous
salle a plutôt l'air cool et puis ça va
avant mes valeurs encore une fois ça va
dans le sens que je veux donner à marie
vivre de ma passion
donc je me lance j'envoie mon cv
entretiens d'embauché un petit peu de
pippo vite fait et je me retrouve
directeur de magasin
j'avais une équipe au top équipe réduite
par contre on a usé de beaucoup de
créativité on s'est vraiment lâché et le
magasin a carrément explosé au delà de
ça donc ça m'a permis de me faire
remarquer dans ce milieu et on m'a
proposé de devenir reporter donc pour
des magazines français ou internationaux
je faisais sans parallèle alors là je me
suis régalé je suis parti partout dans
le monde dans des endroits que je
n'aurais jamais pu me payer non
seulement j'y allais gratuits ont payé
pour ça j'avais mon matos à l'oeil et
j'ai vécu des expériences juste
formidable ça a tellement pris place et
ça marchait tellement bien en plus
jeunes et des sports extrêmes donc
j'avais parlé une touche qui dénotait
voir qui détonnait j'allais chercher des
nouvelles techniques dans des pays
étrangers pour les importer en france
donc ça marchait super bien ça marchait
tellement qu'on m'a proposé de faire ce
job à temps plein et j'avais dans mon
entourage plusieurs personnes qui
faisaient déjà ce genre de métier mais
qui malheureusement se retrouve un petit
peu seul un force de partir à droite à
gauche c'est compliqué et là encore une
fois et si j'assume et le sens que je
veux donner à ma vie fonder une famille
donc j'ai refusé et me voilà parti à
l'assaut d'une nouvelle montagne
acheminés et j'avais aussi une autre
passion dans la vie
au delà des valeurs c'était tout ce qui
était la nature le développement durable
l'environnement et donc je suis tombé
sur une autre annonce et comme quoi il
faut toujours écouter cette petite voix
des fois qui vous dit
là il ya un moment clé là il faut pas
que je le loupe ce petit moment quoi et
donc c'était un poste de direction de
jardinerie écologie que vous connaissez
très bien dans la dans la région moi je
connaissais pas trop je me suis dit on
va un petit peu seront signés et là
whaou
je tombe sur une boîte avec des vraies
valeurs profondément ancré dans ses
actes et dans sa stratégie
et là je me dis ouais ça ça me
correspond ça ça me parle
j'envoie le cv entretiens d embauche là
j'ai été un joueur de pipeau hors pair
en l'occurrence le management tawel pas
de problème j'ai déjà managé des grosses
équipes
des tableaux de bord un compte
d'exploitation
pas de problème je gère désole didier
mes résultats des cours j'ai eu le poste
et me voilà directeur de magasin géré
des équipes d'une bonne cinquantaine de
personnes ont des ménages des
alpes-maritimes
on se retrouve dans le vaucluse petit à
petit je me rapprochais discrètement
mais montagne dans tout allait bien et
là j'avoue que je suis arrivé en pensant
je connaissais beaucoup de choses
finalement une tonne de théories
remplaceront jamais un gramme de
pratique mais après c'est bien beau de
pipeauté mais il faut assumer
c'était écrit tout à l'heure ce qu'ils
méritent d'être faits doit être bien
fait donc j'ai beaucoup travaillé et de
mes faiblesses j'en ai fait des forces
j'ai beaucoup appris sur la gestion le
management la commercialisation la
communication le business dans sa
globalité et surtout par c'est un petit
peu mon karma je suis toujours tomber
sur des entreprises en difficultés
humaines et organisationnelles et petit
à petit étonnamment je me suis
spécialisé dans la conduite au
changement j'ai aussi accompagné dans ma
vie bones enfin plusieurs centaines de
collaborateurs et avec ce postulat que
la quête de sens et est très importante
et que ceux qui ne trouvaient pas de
sens dans leur métier est en véritable
souffrance il est évident quand on est
dans une situation compliquée des fois
la peur du changement ça fait peur on
n'a pas forcément envie de changer tout
simplement parce qu'on sait ce qui va
nous attendre le lendemain matin on se
bouge et c'est déjà plus compliqué et
moi je pars du principe que en se
bougeant
on peut toujours
réussir à aller chercher du mieux
quelque part du coup ça m'a permis de
connaître de plus en plus humain
d'accompagner une multitude de
collaborateurs dans leur quête de sens
voir dans leur burn out au delà de ça je
travaille énormément notamment les
week-ends et les jours fériés
ma fille était née ma première quelques
temps avant et je la voyais finalement
très très peu et puis versez 2 ans à la
poser une question à sa mère en disant
en parlant de moi c'est qui ce monsieur
et là je me suis pris excusez moi
l'expression une baffe dans la gueule
abominable est ce que c'est ça est-ce
que c'était le sens que je voulais
donner à ma vie du coup j'ai décidé
d'arrêter
quel sens je voulais donner à ma vie au
moins être un bon père
du coup mon volant haut d'un nouveau
sommet à contempler ces 360 degrés de
perspectives
cette multitude de chemins empruntés
toujours avec mon everest toujours avec
mon objectif en ligne de mire et en dix
ans mais maintenant je fais quoi
alors là ça a été un brainstorming
permanent j'ai beaucoup beaucoup testé
j'ai semé énormément de choses encore
une fois quand on s'intéresse à tout on
trouve toujours de quoi faire alors j'ai
voulu j'ai testé je voulais me lancer
dans l'élevage de crevettes d'ornement
dans la culture de champignons dans
l'élevage de poules il y avait des
poules qui couraient partout dans la
maison dans la permaculture
j'ai appris à faire du fromage de chèvre
je me suis aussi formé à l'hypnose à la
pnl et le m2m
bref je me suis cherché j'ai testé
encore une fois c'est dans l'action et
puis d'apprendre ça c'est important
qu'est-ce qui va germer qu'est ce qui va
sortir le but de cette semaine
est-ce que ça va être une mauvaise herbe
est-ce que ça va être un art majestueux
en tout cas si on s'aime pas eh ben on
aura du mal à trouver une réponse
et puis dans cette quête de sens
je suis tombé sur une légende
amérindienne racontée par un monsieur
extraordinaire qui s'appelle pierre
rabhi et cette légende dit dans la forêt
amazonienne y avait un feu
dantesque tous les animaux était prostré
dans un coin regarder le carnage voir
leur habitat se faire détruire
il y avait juste un petit colibri qui
s'excite et partent à fond à droite à
gauche
il prenait une petite goutte d'eau il l
acheter dans le feu héros partent et une
goutte d'eau et la jeter dans le feu et
puis avait un tatoo au milieu qui
commence à être exaspérés par toute
cette agitation et qui lui dira au
colibri tu tu te rends pas compte
relativité fou quoi qu'est ce que tu
fais tu arriveras jamais à éteindre le
feu avec ta petite goutte et le colibri
s'arrête un instant il lui répond ouais
je sais mais je vais faire ma part et ça
ça ça a fait tilt et si je faisais ma
part est-ce que ça allait pas être ça le
nouveau sens que j'allais donner à ma
vie mettre mes compétences au profit de
l'autre je crois pas au hasard et
quelques jours après j'ai été contacté
par des chasseurs de têtes qui montre
opposait la responsabilité d'une
association où mes collaborateurs former
des chiens qui étaient confiées
gratuitement à des personnes en
situation de handicap moteur
bref débrief avec mon épouse allez c'est
parti ça a l'air cool on met la gamine
dans la voiture et on déménage du
vaucluse direction les monts du lyonnais
au passage on continue à se rapprocher
un petit peu delà de la savoie et des
montagnes et là j'ai vécu une période de
ma vie extraordinaire très dur un vrai
ascenseur émotionnel
j'ai appris à découvrir le monde du
handicap
bon avec tous les sports extrêmes
j'avoue que je l'avais déjà côtoyé pas
mal de fois et moi aussi j'ai frisé la
correctionnelle mais j'ai découvert j'ai
beaucoup appris de l'humain en
l'occurrence sa capacité à rebondir face
à des grosses épreuves sa bienveillance
sa capacité de résilience
j'ai découvert aussi beaucoup de joie
dans cet univers est vraiment c'est une
époque qui m'a vraiment bouleversée
j'ai aussi appris beaucoup sur moi en
l'occurrence à relativiser les épreuves
à dédramatiser
ça veut pas dire je me fous tous par
contre j'avoue que maintenant je rentre
à la maison
donc ma femme et mes enfants vont en
bonne santé sont en bonne santé
le reste ça prend quand même un petit
peu moins d'importance mon deuxième
enfant est né je voyage et enfin je
bouge beaucoup
j'avais un bon un bon tiers de la france
a à gérer
et donc je suis parti sur une nouvelle
aventure en l'occurrence j'ai récupéré
la direction générale d'une association
de protection des animaux et là j'avoue
j'en ai vraiment pris plein la gueule
j'ai été face à mes antivaleurs à la
souffrance à l'extrémisme aux agressions
aux menaces de mort et j'avoue que ça a
été une partie de ma vie un petit peu un
petit peu compliqué et je suis tombé sur
un texte qui a été tourné à valenciennes
je vous invite d'ailleurs à les leur
garde et de michel toulet rdt j'espère
j'écorche pas son nom et qui met en
avant de manière très intelligente la
différence entre le courage et l'audace
et surtout entre la persévérance et
l'obstination et dans ce métier j'avoue
que au delà de la persévérance j'étais
allé dans l'obstination j'étais aussi
face à beaucoup d'anti valeurs je me
battais contre des moulins à vent et un
moment il a bien fallu se rendre à
l'évidence là je sortais du sens que je
voulais donner à ma vie donc on arrête
et on se retrouve en haute son nouveau
sommet avec cette expérience de dire je
ne perds jamais soit je gagne soit
j'apprends je pars vraiment du principe
que toute expérience même si elle est
mauvaise nous permet de remplir notre
sac à dos de nouvelles compétences et
quand on pose cette question repartir à
zéro
moi je réponds voilà une phrase qu'elle
est con en voilà une phrase qu'elle est
con on ne repart jamais à 0 on remplit
toujours son sac à dos de nouveaux
outils
du coup là j'étais prêt à monter ma
boîte a essayé de compulser tous ces
outils toutes ces valeurs dans une
entreprise qui contenterait donc en
étale ses outils et c'est un petit peu
comme quand on a passé sa vie dans un
magasin de bricolage
on est avec son chariot on remplit son
chariot d'outils divers et variés et à
un moment il est quand même bien de
passer à la caisse et d'utiliser ces
outils
finalement dans un parcours certes un
petit peu atypique avec réflexion toutes
les pièces du puzzle commencent à se
rassembler et amène une vraie cohérence
et là l'idée de dire oui ça ça paraît
être une idée qui va compulser justement
toutes mes valeurs et tout le sens
je veux donner à ma vie et même si cette
bonne graine va pousser dans un terrain
difficile au moins j'ai la possibilité
de la faire grandir et de bien la faire
grandir
du coup déménagement en savoie et avec
mon épouse on a décidé de monter une
structure qui est une coopérative
d'activités d'entrepreneurs qui permet
aux entrepreneurs de créer leur
entreprise et nous on va être là pour
les accompagner et pérenniser leur
structure les aider active et où leur
levier de performance et entre nous pour
aller vers son adresse c'est quand même
plus cool d'y aller en parapente et de
prendre de la hauteur
tout ça pour vous dire une chose dans la
vie
accumuler un maximum de graines vivait
vibrer ne vous interdisez rien soyez
vous lâchez vous dépasser vos limites
et si vous avez cette faculté de vouloir
mettre en avant le sens que vous allez
donner à votre vie vous verrez que non
seulement votre vie sera moins chiante
et au delà de ça que vous le verrez bien
donc cultivez votre jardin
régalez-vous et surtout ayez une vie
flamboyante merci à vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]